this question was submitted by text by a
member of the electrical and electronics
engineers part of the magnetics
community the question is simply what is
spin the speed is a quantum car of some
particle the electrons for example and
is predicted by quantum mechanics and if
I want to explain to somebody with Chile
in physics can say that can imagine that
the spin is related to some rotation of
the charge of the electron around some
axis and then to this orbital rotation
is associated a spin along the axis of
the rotation and also a magnetic moment
and the only difference that has to be
understood is that this rotation must be
quantify and throw also the orientation
of the spin in space is also quantified